a bill that has been proposed in the
state of Idaho would criminalize giving
mRNA vaccines that is the technology in
the vast majority of the covid vaccines
and two Republicans in Idaho have
introduced this bill it would make it a
crime to give people to administer mRNA
vaccines if the bill becomes the law the
Idaho state code would be amended to say
that those administering mRNA vaccines
to any person or mammal within the state
don't you dare give it to a whale would
face misdemeanor charges this is Bonkers
you have people who are not doctors who
are not immunologists who have no
training or expertise in medical science
for political reasons doing something in
response to covet anti-vaxxerism now the
bill doesn't mention covid-19 vaccines
but of course we all know what they're
getting at here